best of all well that craziness the
typical night outside the hottest
celebrity hangout in Hollywood the
nice-guy big names like T Swift Bieber
Selena and all the Kardashians have made
this their go-to spot so why does every
a lister want to hang out at a nice guy
every person is different he set up
special everything and we have their
likes and their needs and what they you
know we have their profile basically on
file it's the place for star-studded
birthday parties to where celebrities
like Kendall and Gigi recently got to
celebrate there's in private no cell
phones allowed in there right no cell
phone no pictures they can be on their
cell phone but no pictures at all and
it's very strict on that co-owner John
terzian did take our cameras inside the
nice guys sister Club the blind dragon a
high-end karaoke lounge with a
paparazzi-free zone the beauty about the
blind dragon you guys are literally in a
parking garage so no paparazzi can get
in is private property private property
and you literally walk through the
kitchen to get in you walk through
garage through the refrigerator through
the kitchen to get into blind dragon and
at their other hot spot Bootsy bellows
the burlesque shows and live music
drawing big crowds but it's the VIP back
room where the real party happens this
room is very loungy it's kind of a
lounge vibe it sometimes gets wild and
fun as often then often this room is the
main place that people do kind of
private very private events after album
releases or concerts or every major
persons kind of come through and done
their party here and you have to walk
through the main club to get through to
this back room so you you do for some
people and then there's also a direct
private entrance for celebrity so people
can literally sneak into this club and
no one will ever know Oh most of the
major people are in and out with
anyone so why do you guys think that you
have such successful night clubs here I
think that the success is probably just
based on we stay really true and good to
our core loyal friends and family and
fortunately for us a lot of those
friends and family kind of became pretty
pretty large stars themselves